englisch aber nicht eigentlich immer
schlecht reden musste scheißen steht
befriedigen - prasselte was gelaufen
jetzt willkommen beim neuen video und
zwar ecke doch bestimmt alle diesem
moment wenn man so eine klausur
wiederbekommt drauf guckt eigentlich
auch schon weiß dass ich scheiße war und
sie ist dann auch scheiße vier oder fünf
also sowas halten
ach ja wenn euch das video gefällt dann
lass doch nach oben und wenn es euch
nicht gefällt es noch nach unten da weil
das ist very important for me that i can
see if you like it or not normalerweise
sagt man ja vorher mal seinen eltern ja
ich schreibe da und da eigene streitig
machte da schreibe ich deutsch und so
weiter und ja wenn man dann halt eine
schlechte klausur geschrieben hat und
nach hause kommt das ist ja dann immer
das gleiche
du sagst eine note und wir ist zehn
minuten langen folgen wie scheiße du
bist dass du das eine schwester kannst
dass du zu wenig gelernt hast und so
weiter und ich wette 95 prozent meiner
zuschauer es gibt ja auch so leute die
schreiben immer eisen ich meine jetzt
ich bin auch nicht so scheiße aber ich
bin es auch nicht mehr gut aber ich bin
es einfach leid wenn ich die fia dann
zehn minuten langen folgen aber zu
werden und irgendwie muss man ja darum
herumkommen die einfachste methode oder
die die halt man als erstes mal
ausprobieren sollte wäre einfach gar
nichts zu sagen also ihr habt eure
klassenarbeiten geschrieben habt ihr
auch wieder bekommen ein paar waren gut
sagte einfach und mathe oder sogar
scheiße sagt einfach gar nichts wenn ihr
jetzt ganz viel glück hat dann haben
eltern das vergessen dass wir machte
geschrieben haben und fertig ich habe
allerdings selbst so viel glück und dann
kommt halt irgendwann diese frage mein
sohn was ist eigentlich mit der
matheklausur müsstest du die nicht
längst schon wieder haben
auf der einen seite könnte man dann
einfach nein sagen und wiederum nochmal
hoffen dass sie es vergessen aber da ist
die chance und halt noch geringer als
sie vorher schon ist ja normalerweise
kommen diese frage dann immer und immer
wieder und irgendwann muss man einfach
alles auf eine karte setzen
ich hab ne 2
ist ok nein ist nein wenn man dann diese
antwort bekommt super gemacht mein sohn
dann kann ich mir den elternsprechtag ja
dieses jahr sparen
viel spaß beim zocken dann habt ihr
glück wenn es aber doch diese antwort
ist nein im moment hier da lassen wir
erstmal sehen hier habt ihr pech es sei
denn eure alte klausur oder heute alte
arbeit war 2 oder halt ziemlich gut
dann kamen ihr die mv schnell raus sagt
ihr und eure eltern bisschen ähnlich und
wann ihr wurzelberechnungen hatte wann
ihr was weiß ich hatte also diesen
ganzen kram den man später nicht mehr
braucht und von daher sollte das dann
okay sein ja das ist jetzt immer so eine
sache weil eigentlich will man seine
eltern ja auch nicht unbedingt an lügen
einmal ist vielleicht okay aber wenn es
öfter so ist dann ist es vielleicht auch
irgendwann
also wenn ihr wirklich auch kein
vermögen wollt dann versucht es einfach
so ich muss dir was sagen ich habe eine
fünf in mathe wie eine 5 ich glaube ich
habe ich richtig gerne fünf halt
mangelhaft nicht ausreichend aber auch
nicht ungenügend so gut ja so geht es ja
nicht hier und lass mich raten die stadt
wieder mit zwei nein die ist total
schlecht ausgefallen sogar peter hat nur
vier mich interessieren aber gar nicht
was die anderen haben logo ist deine
logik bitte dass du willst von mir
wissen war wie die ausgefallen ist ich
sag schlägt und du sagst es interessiert
heute
ich weiß auch nicht überlebt euch also
ganz gut ob ihr euch was anhalt was
überhaupt keinen sinn ergibt oder ob ihr
vielleicht doch wie ist eure sache wie
heute wir sind jetzt hier schon wieder
schön in der entfernt und ich würde
sagen in seinem weiher eben alles ein
gewinn findet ihr auch in der video
beschreibung hier oben geht es jetzt
weiter mit einem video das war dinge die
jugendliche heimlich tun checkt es auch
auf jeden fall ab würde mich vorhin
abonniert nicht vergessen und nichts
verpassen wir sehen uns mittwoch wieder
hunderte auf 15 uhr einschalten nicht
vergessen